why Mars what's so magical about Mars
because Mars is the closest planet that
has on it all the materials needed to
support life and technological
civilization on Mars there are glaciers
on Mars that have uh more water than the
American Great Lakes there are
continent-sized regions that are 60
Water by weight in the soil the Mars got
a carbon dioxide dominated atmosphere
carbon is fundamental to life there's no
Carbon on the moon at all the nitrogen
exists on Mars it doesn't exist on the
moon so these are the fundamental things
for life and Mars is a 24-hour day which
is what plants want it we can set up
greenhouses and grow food
the Martian atmosphere as soon as this
can mask out solar flares I really like
musk's approach to engineering which is
you build a lot of them you fly in the
crash them you fix the next one try
again they're going to look at this and
say well this guy wants to go to Mars if
we got together with him uh and
developed all the rest of the stuff
that's needed I think we can have people
walking around on Mars 10 years from now
and I think we can have very substantial
bases on Mars starting to develop this
technology and maybe even the first
children born on Mars 20 years from now
you know for Our Generation uh Mars is
the New World
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology apology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is an
aerospace engineer author and an
advocate for the human exploration of
Mars Dr Robert Zuber and welcome to
trigonometry thanks for inviting me oh
it's such a pleasure to have you on we
have got a ton of questions for you both
from us and from our audience before we
get to all of those tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what
has been the journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us about space exploration and many
other things we're going to talk about
okay uh well I'm kind of a time traveler
here's an art attack my period
um the uh I um was born in 52 and uh my
first memory of any major world event in
terms of direct experience was Sputnik
was five and um
I was already a reader reading science
fiction and while the adults may have
been terrified of Sputnik I was
delighted with it it meant that space
travel was going to be real I wanted to
be part of that and my parents
encouraged my interest
um so
uh you know my father got me a telescope
and I did drawings of the Moon through
the eyepiece and I launched rockets and
did all that stuff and you know in the
60s
I was all in you know we were going to
the Moon by 1970 Mars by 1988 Saturn by
1990 Alpha Centauri by the year 2000 and
and I wanted to be part of that
um now uh we did achieve the first
milestone in that program we did make it
to the Moon before in 1970.
um but the rest of it was put aside
um and at least the next step in it was
in fact achievable NASA actually had
plans to send humans to Mars by 1981 the
Nixon Administration canceled them and
uh
so at the same time that uh you know
Nixon was enjoying celebrating the
Apollo achievements and writing and the
ticker tape parades with astronauts they
were actually shutting down uh the
assembly lines uh wrecking it it was as
if Columbus had come back from the new
world the first time and Ferdinand and
Isabella had said so what let's burn the
ship
um and um so the thing went around and
um
so I by then was in college and the real
world got to me that in the real world
you know people don't grow up to be
Space Explorers that's the television
people that is the people on the other
side of the TV screen who live in that
world uh and in fact not many of them
are going to be going to the Moon either
and uh so gotta get real and so I became
a science teacher and because I had
Science Education I could do that and
it's a noble profession I I I'm the kind
of person that I I have to understand a
purpose to what I'm doing uh and so that
that does fulfill that uh but you know
around a decade later you know I'm
living in North Manhattan and teaching
in Brooklyn and riding the subway an
hour each way every day and reading
novels by Herman Neville Melville about
sailing the South Seas and saying you
know what am I doing here and
um
and so
I decided to go back to graduate school
and become an engineer and I did and
um
and then I heard about these people of
my own generation who were members of
this thing called the Mars underground
who were trying to push for a Visionary
Space Program NASA by this time had
embraced the idea of a space program the
shuttles putting satellites in Earth
orbit because you know that's practical
going to planets that's the dreams of
Youth forget it and they said no that's
what we should be doing and so I got
connected with them became a member of
the Mars underground myself then I
managed to get hired at an aerospace
company Martin Marietta which is now
Lockheed Martin
um and uh started making my Mark at uh
planetary Mission design and uh and then
I I became very well known when I I was
one of the two principal authors of a
new way of approaching human Mars
missions called the Mars direct plan
um and uh which basically was sort of a
travel light and live off the land
approach to sending humans to Mars and
it got away from trying to build giant
spaceships and Earth orbit at Giant
space stations which would not exist
until the 22nd century or any of that
stuff and
uh
well uh became well known
um got contented by a literary agent
when there was an article about me in
Newsweek and
um she said
have you ever thought about writing a
book about this I said well you know I
wrote a book once before and I couldn't
get it published and she said what kind
of book was that I said spy novel she
said were you ever a spy I said no uh
you know did you have a literary agent
no uh well you are an astronautical
engineer and I am a literary agent and
if you write this book I will get it
published and that is what happened and
I wrote the case for Mars and she got it
published and it became uh
well not exactly a bestseller but a very
high seller internationally and
um I got thousands of letters from
people who read it and I got together
with other Mars underground types and I
said look if we could pull these people
together we'd have
Force we'd have something that could
actually make this Vision happen because
that the the diversity of people who had
contacted us which included not only
engineers at JPL and astronauts and
people like this but you know firemen
and Saskatoon and 12 year old kids in uh
Poland and the director of the
Metropolitan Opera in I forget New York
and a banker in Paris it was incredible
and the the you know pull them together
we could do something so we founded the
marsh society and that was in 98
it was covered in the New York Times the
BBC all over the place and we came out
of it with chapters and about 25
countries including most of the major
countries and a few ones you wouldn't
expect
um and um you know we're still here so
there I am the there you are a bit well
let me ask you the question that you've
kind of alluded to when you were talking
about your childhood because uh my
father was born in the Soviet Union
about 10 years after you uh the year
after Yuri Gagarin became the first man
to go into space uh and then 20 years
later 20 years later when I was born you
know my generation we read Isaac Asimov
and all of this stuff about space and
robots and uh all of that
um and uh this was a moment of
excitement when I think we looked out
into space with a sense of that almost
being our destination to to go out and
to explore the universe but in in the
last 20 years it doesn't feel like we've
been having that conversation to me
we've been very focused internally even
when we talk about things like the
destruction of the earth that some
people would begin to talk about we
never other than Elon Musk I've never
really heard anyone talking in public
about about the idea that even with that
the solution might be to ensure the
resilience of of human human species by
going beyond Earth so what happened why
did we lose our excitement our Zeal for
for going out into space and exploring
it well I as I mentioned there was an
enormous failure in leadership on the
part of governments in terms of
abandoning the program at the point of
success and then the quality of
political leadership in
um most governments deteriorated
markedly in the following period so that
they were not able to resume any such
project
um and uh
you know if I compare either Trump or
Biden to John F Kennedy I mean really
um it's a joke or compare recent uh
British leadership to Winston Churchill
or the macron to Charles de Gaulle I
mean
it's ridiculous uh the the the however
um
precisely because the political classes
dropped the ball there's a new group
that has stepped forward and that's the
entrepreneurial uh uh leaders I mean in
the 60s no one would have looked for an
entrepreneurial leader to to save the
day from a failing NASA NASA wasn't
failing
um but uh you know
starting in the 70s the 80s and 90s you
know for a while I mean I certainly hope
that NASA would you know just sort of
recover
and and and I mean that was certainly my
Outlook uh and uh was skeptical of the
people who said that they would save the
day with the private companies
um But as time went on and the
government continued to underperform and
the private companies in particular
SpaceX over performed I've altered my
view
uh and now it's a real possibility again
but I'd like to come back to something
more fundamental
that you alluded to
which is
um
this more pessimistic view of the future
um I think that that is the greatest
threat facing Humanity
um the
um
we're not destroying the Earth uh I
don't think we're capable of destroying
the Earth how we're damaging certain
places the rainforest we're also
improving certain places uh but we are
in danger of destroying each other
um and the thing that will drive us to
destroy each other is the same thing
that caused the mega disasters of the
20th century which is the belief that
there isn't enough for everyone
this belief that there's only so much
here to go around and so we have to kill
them to get it okay you know 1912.
Friedrich Von Bern Hardy the chief
intellectual a German general staff
wrote a book it became an international
bestseller in English titles Germany in
the next War
still available
as a Kindle book
um that and when she said look you know
here's Eurasia who's going to get it
it's either going to be us Germans or
the Russians we're going to have to have
it out with them should it be sooner or
later well clearly sooner because we can
take them down now because they haven't
industrialized yet
and then you know a quarter Century
later Hitler even more hysterically you
know Germany needs living space the laws
of existence require uninterrupted
killing so the better may live this was
all nonsense Germany never needed living
space Germany today is smaller than the
Third Reich has a larger population and
a vastly higher standard of living and
how did they achieve that not by
invading other countries and murdering
people and killing and stealing their
cows okay they were openly unsuccessful
in that program uh and had they
succeeded in that program it would not
have made them any richer at all uh the
Germany today is vastly richer than it
was in the 1930s because of the advance
of science and technology which is a
global human project through which
Germans have contributed certainly uh
but so have numerous other peoples
including those they were trying to
exterminate and the the the
um and and so it's not true that the
human condition is one one of
um antagonistic races in the struggle
for existence over limited resources
um rather the truth is that
we are a somewhat disorderly family of
Nations very disorderly family of
Nations to be sure but nonetheless a
family engaged in a joint project to
create new possibilities through new
technologies and and you know inventions
made anywhere sooner or later become
used everywhere
um
so I mean is America the enemy of China
well China is uh uh is enormously
Advanced it's it's standard of living
over the past 30 years because of
inventions like electricity and and
iPhones and everything that were created
in the west but the West itself had its
Renaissance Because Of Inventions like
paper and printing that were made in
China and the the the so
but nevertheless if we have this
zero-sum point of view
we could end up killing each other and
we're fundamentally in a pre-war
situation right now because of this
point of view okay for Putin war is
inevitable and so he must acquire
Ukraine in order to strengthen his
strategic position and
you know and that's exactly why he must
be denying Ukraine actually aside from
the fact that ukrainians don't want to
get killed uh as far as everybody else
is concerned
that's it and the the
but this is all Insanity there is no
reason for war human right human race
today it's the largest population and
the highest standard living by far
than it has ever had in human history
but you know that was also true in 1914.
Robert I mean it's it's a very powerful
thing that you're saying here
the question that I would like to ask is
why space exploration so important
because there will be people who go why
are we going out there when we've got
poverty you know addiction all of these
different things these huge problems
that we haven't managed to solve in our
own countries why are we investing so
much in space well we're not really
investing somewhere okay okay the NASA
budget is less than one why should we
actually
but they're less than one half of one
percent of the federal budget okay so I
I am not suggesting that we should shut
down the public school system so we
could devote that money Mr space
exploration
um but you know
um
the fact that there are people hungry
today is not a reason to eat the seed
corn
um and uh in fact that's a very bad move
uh now
there are three reasons here
okay going to space is
um
is going to get us a lot of knowledge
and by the way there's nothing more
valuable than knowledge uh the you know
frankly the reason why people live
better today than they did a hundred
years ago or a thousand years ago is
because of knowledge
um
sorry to interrupt what knowledge will
we get from going out into space that
could then come and enrich life on earth
oh any amount I mean uh for instance
um most of what we know about physics we
gain through astronomy
uh Newton's Laws uh a lot of
electromagnetism relativity nuclear
fusion all came to astronomy and there's
a reason why because the universe is the
biggest and best lab there is and you
can discover phenomena there that you
hadn't suspected existed before and the
the the the and believe me our knowledge
of physics today is not complete it is
not complete in fact it makes no sense
uh I mean it's useful I'm an engineer I
use it all the time but if for instance
you take the most basic law of physics
matter cannot be created or destroyed
well then tell me how was this created
there it is okay you've got a law of
physics that's in direct Defiance uh uh
of of not only some data but all the
data uh and the the the you know so if
we could discover a greater degree of
truth about the true laws of physics
it would have enormous applications the
laws of biology are very incompletely
known all life on Earth uses the same
biochemical system DNA RNA it's one
system for recording uh and using
biological information and now look we
speak English
okay uh and we use the Latin alphabet so
do the French Spanish Germans even the
polls okay so if you travel around in
our parts of the world you might think
that that's what an alphabet is
but of course in Russian they use a
somewhat different alphabet although it
works on the same set of principles
in Israel or Arab countries they use an
even more difficult different alphabet
although it still works on the same set
of principles because they're all have a
common origin in The Phoenician alphabet
but the Chinese alphabet is totally
different it it not only is it different
characters it is works on a completely
different set of principles and yet it
does the same thing you can write books
in it okay and
so here's the biology and bioengineering
is going to be one of the great
technological Sciences of the 21st
century and yet we only know about one
system one information system it's like
only knowing about PCS and and not
understanding there could be things like
Max okay let alone DNA computers or
other kinds of compute or human Minds so
if we can discover alternative types of
biology our capabilities in the
bioengineering area or to be enormously
expanded and um because right now we're
just like linguists who are only
acquainted with one language and are
unaware of the existence of other
languages they don't know what languages
they only know what English is
um and and so
the games could be phenomenal
so that being the case so you've made a
case for space exploration very well why
Mars what's so magical about mods what
why does my why is Mars so important to
you
because Mars is the closest planet that
has on it all the materials needed
um to support life and technological
civilization
um it's vastly richer and useful
materials than uh the moon for example
um the moon uh
most of the moon is so bereft in water
that if they found Concrete On The Moon
they would mine it for its water
um
there is potentially some water and
permanently shadowed craters near the
South Pole of the Moon
um but under extremely Ultra you know 40
Kelvin conditions uh
on Mars there are glaciers on Mars that
have uh more water than the American
Great Lakes there are continent-sized
regions that are 60 Water by weight in
the soil that that the Mars has got a
carbon dioxide dominated atmosphere
carbon is fundamental to life there's no
Carbon on the moon at all the nitrogen
exists on Mars it doesn't exist on the
moon so these are the fundamental things
for life they don't exist on the moon
they exist on Mars and then about half
the elements needed by industry don't
exist on the moon whereas they do all
exist on Mars and furthermore Mars has
had a complex geological history which
is necessary for differentiating
elements into useful ores and the moon
hasn't had that
[Music]
um
and Mars is a 24-hour day which is what
plants want it
the Martian atmosphere is the news this
can mask out solar flares uh you know
for Our Generation uh Mars is the New
World
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
and uh you talk about uh some of the
things that make Mars an appealing place
to go to how
how close are we from having the
technology we have to go because from my
very Layman understanding the problem
isn't just being able to get there
obviously you need to get be able to get
back the problem is can you have people
travel that far uh without physical
problems you know can you do you have
the technology for people to be able to
survive on Mars etc etc how far are we
from being actually being if like if we
said today we want to go and we're
prepared to use whatever resources and
money that we have how far away are we
from actually being able to go to Mars
or send some people to Mars that more
likely well uh if you post it that way I
I would say five years if if you
ask it more for a prediction I would say
10
um the
um
you know there's all sorts of Hardware
that needs to be developed but we're not
talking about Los Alamos 1943 here we're
not talking about venturing into new
Realms of physics
we're talking about engineering uh we're
talking about
creating things done doing it right not
making mistakes and people make mistakes
and so you know this is why I really
like musk's approach to engineering
which is you build a lot of them you're
flying but crash them you fix the next
one try again
um the the uh uh you know because yeah
we make mistakes
um but if you push through that you get
it right and
um and I think uh you know Starship
if it's not blocked by bureaucrats uh
it'll probably reach orbit next year and
be reaching orbit frequently in 2024 and
um
and if that's the reality that we have
in the year 2024 you know we're gonna
have a president elected here then
um and if you know we've got these ships
going to orbit with 100 ton payloads
comparable to a Saturn V Moon rocket but
one percent the cost because they're
reusable instead of expendable
they're going to look at this and say
well this guy wants to go to Mars if we
got together with him uh and developed
all the rest of the stuff that's needed
could we get there by the end of my
second term the answer is going to be
yes well is it going to cost a trillion
dollars no we could probably do it
within NASA's existing budget because
he's already developed the flight system
um well then why aren't we doing this in
other words by by making it practical
musk is going to make it sellable
um now
if musk skates off the edge of the ice
which could happen because he's a risk
taker it'll take somewhat longer but I
think if if SpaceX should fail other
entrepreneurial companies will step up
and pick up the flag because he's
already proven
that these entrepreneurial approach can
work and work great and so uh regardless
of his own particular circumstances he's
already basically proven the point
um at the essential point and what would
the first first voyage to Mars look like
is it a moon landing type of thing where
you you get off you collect some samples
you plant a flag in the ground and you
you get out of there or are you looking
more to establish a some kind of
permanent presence there well even if
it's just robotic to start well there
are different Visions associated with
this but if you ask for mine
um
uh I believe that first of all uh that
is not the right approach we do not want
to do a flags and Footprints Mars
mission that's not why you go to Mars I
think we need a purpose-driven program
and the purpose of early Mars missions
is exploration
uh and then later settlement but let's
take the first thing first exploration
requires time on the surface
okay so there's actually two different
trajectories you can take to Mars one is
one that fits in with the flags and
Footprints approach which involves
spending about two years in transit in
one month on the surface two years and
two unequal legs totaling two years uh
and a month on the surface that's known
as the opposition class Mission
um the other is known as the conjunction
class Mission which is the one that I
support which involves
a total of two and a half years for the
mission but a year to a year and a half
of it is on the surface and the
remainder uh is spent in transit so for
instance six months out six months back
a year and a half on the surface and uh
so instead of sending five percent of
the mission time on Mars you spend sixty
percent of the mission time on Mars and
you do a comprehensive program of
regional field exploration while you're
there uh that's the right way to do it
uh now
Musk
wants to move directly to settlement but
I I believe that we need a certain
amount of exploration to choose the best
place to put the settlement
and what would it what would it look
like Robert in your in your eyes to have
a colony on mars or to live on Mars
because it's beginning to become it's
going to be fundamentally fundamentally
different to life on Earth isn't it
well sure
um
I mean we're going someplace new uh now
I get asked this question
um a lot what's going to be the
political system what's going to be uh
the social mores and so forth we're just
thinking practically at this point like
physically what is it going to look like
are you going to have to walk around in
the suit and all of that live in a
biodome
okay
you can make domes uh but with
present-day materials they would have to
be of limited size not more than 100
meters in diameter because otherwise the
pressure in them would blow them up uh
but you could have a lot of hundred
meter domes and Link them together with
tunnels and stuff like this
um you could have domes and then
um have a more extended living quarters
underneath them uh imagine
um you know systems like the underground
uh you know subway system as it were but
designed as living quarters okay
essentially things that are kind of like
shopping malls but you could put housing
in them and all that the purpose of
doing that
um would be first of all you have a lot
more housing space within a given dome
but also people would spend most of
their time
uh underground which means shielded from
cosmic radiation completely now
the radiation dose on the Martian
surface is essentially the same as that
at the International Space Station and
people go there they go there routinely
for six months at a time and I think the
longest one's about a year and a half
and we haven't seen any radiological
effects but if you did want to limit the
dose more than that you would could
spend uh the majority of your time
within living quarters that are
underground and only come up into the
Dome to walk around and enjoy the
Orchards and you know play baseball uh
but probably wouldn't play baseball
probably more Martian sports that are
more uh economical in terms of the use
of space volleyball basketball uh the
these kinds of things
um the um
uh but uh but I mean how much of your
time do you spend outside right now
except for Farmers most people spend
less than ten percent of their time
Outdoors
uh and uh that'd be two and a half hours
a day a lot of people don't spend that
much time Outdoors so if you spend ten
percent of your time in the dome and the
rest of it underground
um then your radiation dose would be one
tenth of that of the ISS
um so that would solve that problem uh I
think that um
Martian cities need to be designed to be
functional
and beautiful
why
clearly functional why beautiful because
the Martian cities that grow will be the
ones that attract the most immigrants
and no one's going to want to live in uh
you know the environment like that of
the city in Total Recall
um you know the they wouldn't want to go
there similarly I don't think Martian
cities can be tyrannies because no one
would emigrate to one of them uh Martian
cities will be experiments
um and the winners will be those that
um attract the most immigrants
um and so that's also my answer to the
social system as well the one that
people find the most attractive you know
at the time of the American Revolution
Caribbean islands had a bigger economy
than the 13 colonies okay that's why the
Battle of Yorktown the British Fleet
didn't come to rescue cornwalls because
they were busy stealing islands in the
Caribbean from the French
um because they were worth a lot more uh
in dollars or pounds
um
but in the time after that
the United States so outpaced Caribbean
as well as Latin America in European
immigration because it was a much more
attractive place for people to move to
uh for any number of reasons uh and thus
it became you know an economic and
political superpower uh while the
Caribbean islands you know a pretty
minor Affair in global
um calculations today
um and uh so that's what's going to
determine it that the noble experiments
on Mars
different political system
different physical architectures
different mores different customs
the ones that Prevail will be the ones
that people find the most attractive and
what would the Martian economy or
economies be based around because
obviously there's a huge initial
investment not only to get human beings
there but to build even the first dome I
imagine would be a very costly Affair is
there an economic rationale to all of
this
uh yeah I think that could be
um now of course this is a tricky
business the projectors that um
advocated colonization in North America
in the Elizabethan age uh you know
look for items that
weren't there like gold
or a Passage to India
um the uh some
when they discovered they could grow
tobacco that that that started to work
uh there were Fisheries that could be
supported out of New England that
started to work timber for the Navy that
started but in other words a lot of
these uh things that they look for
um were wrong
Sometimes some of them guess right uh
but actually the biggest economic game
that Europe got out of America wasn't
timber for the Royal Navy
um it was steamboats telegraphs
electrical light bulbs uh airplanes uh
nuclear power the internet that is
the way in which uh America has
benefited Europe and the world has been
as an engine of invention
and not not a particular product uh in
the
I I think Mars will be a terrific engine
of invention uh many of the same things
that drove America to be a very
inventive culture will exist on Mars but
to uh orders of magnitude higher degree
uh that is for instance the labor
shortage which drove us to gadgeteering
and labor-saving Machinery
um the the the
much more intense on Mars so I think the
Martians are going to be virtuosos not
only in labor-saving machinery and
Automation and Robotics and artificial
intelligence uh all these things that
they will need to compensate for their
labor shortage will have tremendous
benefits to the Earth
um and they'll be licensable here as
patents and that is one way they'll get
income I think also they're going to be
driven to want to create Ultra
productive Greenhouse agriculture uh
because of limited acreage and once
again and so they're going to be uh
virtuosos at GMO uh
bioengineering and so forth and once
again these will have enormous benefits
to the Earth
um
fusion power you know okay there's some
people working at fusion power right now
on Earth but there isn't really a sense
of urgency there we have lots of other
ways you can make electricity you can
burn oil or gas or coal you can have
waterfalls or windmills uh
you know you can have nuclear fission
reactors
um but
um most of that does not exist on Mars
and while you could use nuclear fission
reactors on Mars the fuel for them
requires a great industrial base to
refine uranium ore
um feet which won't exist on Mars the
the
but Mars deuterium which is the heavy
isotope of hydrogen is five times as
common on Mars as it is on Earth and
that's the fuel for Fusion reactors
um and you know
British
invented the steam engine
early America invented the steam boat
okay
why because the only real highways we
had were Rivers
um sailboats really don't do that well
it's transportation in rivers because
the the current can be too strong you
need powered boats and we figured out a
way to put the steam engine to use and
and
in order to make Steam Engines uh
Compact and efficient enough to power
steamboats we had to go to higher
pressure and more efficient engines
which then made possible railroads which
okay Brit invented but this is how this
thing went and
um the
um
but then railroad systems of great
expanse were pioneered here uh and
I I think that uh you know just as steam
engines were really only made efficient
when they were forced to be disciplined
to meet the requirements of a steamed
boat and then even more efficient for a
railroad
um and nuclear reactors frankly the
first practical nuclear reactors were on
submarines
uh and that remains the one place where
they are unchallenged
um
because their capabilities for submarine
propulsion are unique whereas for
electricity generation there are
competing Technologies the the
Fusion may very well be developed uh by
Mars because they will have the
necessity for it
um and then of course uh it may be
Advanced considerably when it is try
made more compact to drive spacecraft
and Robert what are going to be the
challenges of going to Mars and starting
a new Colony on a new planet and what
are also going to be the dangers because
I mean I'm an absolute Layman when it
comes to this to me that the dangers are
multiple aren't they really now
there's dangers here too
um the uh no there's gonna be dangers uh
look if you're if a person's values
are that the good life is one of comfort
and security
uh they should probably not choose being
a first generation Marsh colonist
um if a person's idea of the good life
is one of
doing Deeds of great significance
then they might want to consider it
um that that is it okay those are two
different uh ideas of the good life and
um
you know uh
now I I I'm obviously more in sympathy
to the second point of view but
Different Strokes for different folks uh
I'm not asking everybody to move to Mars
um the
only those people should move to Mars
who want to create a new branch of human
civilization who want to uh open up a
new kind of human future now
if you look at the three most remarkable
and counter-intuitive
um
colonization uh episodes of recent
history I would list the pilgrims going
to Massachusetts the Mormons going to
Utah and the Jews going to Palestine uh
as examples
um in that you know I mean look
Massachusetts was much colder than
England uh and the pilgrims were were
doing just fine in Holland in fact they
left because the Dutch were too nice and
they were assimilating them they wanted
to have their own world and half of them
died in the first winter in New England
because it was much colder than uh
England or Holland uh you know it's
selling it to me Robinson
what I said you're not selling it to me
I was joking no but we hit what I'm
telling you is this is that these people
did these things going to unfavorable
places so they could have their own
world yes got you okay and in all three
examples they were motivated by
transcendic ideas
that went beyond economics
um the religious ideas and things that
went along with that in terms of being
able to make their own world which is a
a fundamental kind of freedom
uh and uh
so they did it now
I think that
people who the initial Martian colonists
will need to have comparable zeal
um because in other words they're going
to have to have a sense of mission
uh an understanding that what they're
doing is important in order to take on
the hardships and risks associated with
this
um but you know there's no free lunch
you stay here you're gonna die here okay
uh you know
um
so the question is is what do you do
with your life and I I believe there'll
be people that'll be up for it no I'm
sure I guess what Francis was more
coming out it's not like we're trying to
dissuade people from going to Mars I
think I'm actually really inspired by
what you're saying in many ways whether
I myself would go I don't know
um but
um I I suppose I we're just curious
about the technical difficulties
obviously the the colonizations that
you've talked about that would have been
the the local climate would have been a
challenge the the sometimes hostile
native population would have been a
challenge uh distance from the the or
Original Point of Departure would have
been a big challenge in terms of getting
manufactured goods and things like that
initially so what are going to be the
biggest you know technological
challenges in terms of going to Mars and
eventually having a colonial Mars okay I
want to stick strictly okay first of all
there's the transportation system
um and this is is being worked on uh
both by SpaceX and by a number of other
entrepreneurial companies as well as at
a much slower Pace by official space
agencies
um
you know this is a solvable problem
then uh from life support
um
we basically have it as far as the
transit is concerned
um you know that
space station recycle some materials
others are just replaced but if you made
a space station like life support system
for the Mars Transit vehicle and made it
sufficiently redundant to to
um
be robust against failure you can do
this
um and you know the routine stay on the
space station is six months
um which is how long it takes to fly
from Earth to Mars with chemical
propulsion today uh the the
number of our recent Mars probes went to
Earth to Mars in bad amount of time
um so it's not futuristic uh the
uh okay life support
um Landing well we land things on Mars
it is a challenging thing to do uh but
it can be done and uh you know I think
if we're sending Starships or something
like this to Mars we're going to send
the first five or six with no one in
them and we'll probably crash the first
three and
then
we'll get it right and and be able to
land them routinely in others will
exercise the technology before we commit
people to it
um the
uh uh okay then life support on Mars is
actually easier than life support and
space because the Mars has got water
it's got carbon dioxide there's
materials there to to work with we can
set up greenhouses and grow food
um now part of the trick of this will be
to do greenhouse agriculture with a
minimum of human labor
okay because there's a lot of other
things to do on Mars
um both by necessity and by choice and
you don't want to commit the large
majority or even a significant fraction
of your time to Growing the plants
you're going to have to vote some
because I don't think any totally
automated system will do the job but I
think you can
greatly reduce the amount of actual time
in the greenhouse and once there are
children on Mars I think that's a place
where they can help out
um and I I think that'll be useful
actually not not just to the Colony but
to them
um
the
uh what are some of the other issues uh
some things that are overblown are dust
storms uh you don't want to land during
a dust storm because the winds can be
high
and if you're coming down as an
aerodynamic dominated object they could
take you and crash you uh but once
you're on the surface they're not really
a problem other than impairing
visibility and solar power because the
in other words the thing they have in
the movie The Martian where the
Windstorm is blowing over the base is
fiction the the air is too thin for the
at the wind to have much force
um the uh you know but we're going to
have to develop Technologies to
um
make the con the base as
self-sufficient as possible in
particular with bulk materials that
includes food water oxygen it also
includes things like plastic steel
aluminum uh glass
um and now I think that can all be done
the materials are there the Technologies
are fairly straightforward although they
have to be repackaged now to make
something like this is more complicated
okay
um so I think for some time Mars is
going to have to import high-tech
objects but even this thing here most of
the weight of this is like the glass
cover and the metal
back and you know the guts of this that
is actually high tech is is maybe 20 of
its mass so this is maybe 200 grams
maybe 40 grams of this is actually
something you can't make on Mars
um now that's the most expensive car but
as
things are shippable by Advanced
transportation to the extent they have a
high
value per Miss
in other words you don't ship coal by
Air Freight
okay because the cost to Air Freight is
is much higher than the value per
kilogram of coal okay shipping this by
air Freights no problem at all
um the the now space Freight is the same
fundamental issue we're not going to
want to ship food and steel to Mars
except at the very initiation of the
base okay so you want to build
greenhouses on Mars so you can make the
steel frame you can make the glass okay
on Mars okay those are the heaviest
stuff you can probably make the motors
that power the pumps and fans for the
greenhouse on Mars too
but the computers that control the
motors uh and fans you probably want to
import from Earth
um and so so you see what I'm saying
um now as Mars becomes
more populated and has a greater
division of labor more sophisticated
objects will be makeable there
um but that's
going to be a progressive thing do you
have a website or do you plan to have a
website because if you do then easy DNS
is a company for you easy DNS is the
perfect domain name registrar provider
and web host for you they have a track
record of standing up for their clients
whether it be cancel culture D platform
attacks or overzealous government
agencies he knows about that so will you
in a second easy DNS have Rock Solid
Network infrastructure and fantastic
customer support they're in your corner
no matter what the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you know about
that move your domains and websites over
to easy DNS right now all you've got to
do is go to easydns.com forward slash
triggered that's easydns.com forward
slash triggered use our promo code which
is also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter accessories see which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
it's really interesting the way that
you're speaking about this Robert and
you'll because to most people this
sounds like something out of a Sci-Fi
novel or a sci-fi movie but the way
you're talking about it shows that you
know that it is achievable it is
achievable and it's going to be in the
Realms of possibility so do you think
that these kind of how long do you think
it's going to take before we set up
these kind of
civilizations these kind this type of
Technology on Mars you think it's going
to be a hundred years or could it be
less than that I think it'd be a lot
less than that let me tell you a story
about this okay it's an interesting
story
in 1970 Apollo Astronauts visited the
crater aristarchus on the moon
and uh the crater aristarchus is the
scene where Arthur Clark set one of his
uh uh most famous novels called
earthlight
okay and the Apollo Astronauts were
aware of this novel and so Landing in
the crater one of them proudly
proclaimed you know we are here in the
crater aristarchus the scene of Arthur
Clark's great novel earthlight and uh
wouldn't he be proud to know if it that
we're here if he was alive today
okay now of course Arthur Clark was
alive in 1970
and he heard this remark and so he
commented on it publicly he said well
you know I actually I am alive and I am
very proud of this but I wrote that
novel in 1940 while I was Manning a
radar station in England during the
Blitz
okay and this is how he was spending the
boredom between attacks writing Earth
flight and he said and if anybody had
told me then
that 30 years later there would be
people walking around in that crater
I would have thought it was the wildest
poppycock imaginable
it's only 30 years that separate the
Blitz from Walking on the Moon
30 years wow okay uh
and Things Can Happen much faster than
we anticipate I think we can have people
walking around on Mars 10 years from now
and I think we can have very substantial
bases on Mars starting to develop this
technology and maybe even the first
children born on Mars 20 years from now
um the the
I think that that future is entirely
possible but
it's not Destiny there's no such thing
as Destiny the future is what we make it
Robert that's a really fascinating way
to talk about it I have to thank you for
kind of recapturing the the spirit of
curiosity in terms of exploring space
that I certainly remember from my
childhood that I haven't felt for a very
long time so thank you for that I really
appreciate it we've got about 10-15
minutes left and I wanted to talk did
you want to do something very quickly
this is not just about Mars it's
something I I have to ask and I would
kick myself if I didn't and it's going
to sound like a ridiculous question but
here we go Robert uh what is your
opinion of alien life forms do you think
that they exist do you think that there
is intelligent alien life form out there
uh sure
um yeah I
I'm pretty certain that there's
intelligent alien life forms out there I
think we're living in a living Universe
um now that's a question of belief
because it you don't have the data that
proves that at the moment
uh except that here's what we know
uh we know from the Kepler space
telescope uh that
um planets around stars are the rule not
the exception okay and uh
and that 20 of the stars in the Milky
Way galaxy uh have earth-sized planets
orbiting stars in their habitable zone
that is the right distance from the Star
where you get that reasonable
temperatures where water is liquid and
not all Frozen or all gaseous or
something like that
um
so the potential homes for Mar for life
are innumerable
um the
uh there's no reason to believe that the
processes that led to the origin of life
from chemistry are unique to the Earth
you know that that's just just doesn't
make any sense uh the the the
um
you know a Roman philosopher I believe
said you know is it reasonable to assume
that an entire field only one blade of
grass should grow well no it's not okay
and furthermore even if life didn't
originate in multiple places it can
travel across space we get rocks from
Mars landing on Earth all the time uh
500 kilograms of them a year uh and
examination of them have shown that in
the process of their ejection from Mars
which is by meteor impact fly through
space and re-entry and landing on Earth
there are large uh fractions of those
rocks that were never raised above 40
Centigrade which means that if there
were microbes in them they could survive
the trip and the rocks are going the
other way too and you know
when the Earth was impacted say the time
of the dinosaur extinction it spread
rocks containing microbes out into space
Not Just To Mars but into Interstellar
space uh and and all other planets that
might have life are doing this too so
any planet that has life is is spreading
life uh now okay that's microbes but
then we know about evolution
and we know that life continuously
evolves and while it's not true that
life evolves in a you know
in a directed way towards higher and
higher forms
evolved in all directions okay which
includes towards higher and higher forms
okay you know people say Well only
humans are intelligent we have
intelligence is a unique human thing
well intelligence is really Shades of
Gray
um you know if you look at the array of
life on Earth uh say as it was uh 30
million years ago long before they were
people but it was diverse mammals uh
vastly more intelligent than the animals
were 300 million years ago
um and they in turn were vastly more
intelligent than the life forms that
were here three billion years ago
um so yes there is progress that occurs
in biology it doesn't occur in Just One
Direction okay we got new viruses being
mutated too but
um
the idea that intelligence which is one
form of adaptation that is useful would
not evolve elsewhere it makes no sense
the intelligence capacity for
intelligence adaptability uh uh um
communicative and cognitive abilities
all have been increasing on Earth uh
more or less continually uh for the past
three billion years uh and um so if
life's everywhere I think it means
intelligence is quite widespread as well
very interesting well I'm glad Francis
asked you that question because the
question I was going to ask you is about
matters back here on Earth which you
alluded to somewhat right at the
beginning of the interview which is
as well I feel like the conversation
we've just had is all about expanding
Humanity beyond the the remed of Earth
and you know growing the impact of human
civilization on the universe and
reaching further and grasping for more
but there is a tendency particularly in
modern society which is I would argue
quite anti-humanist that sees human
beings as a plague that is Unleashed on
this planet uh you know even the mere
mention of colonization obviously has
its negative connotations for for a good
reason historically speaking but I think
underneath that there is a kind of
anti-humanism more broadly which is the
idea that you know having children is
bad that human beings are inherently bad
the impact that we have on the world is
defined by its negative impact on the
world and so on uh where does that come
from in your opinion why have we some
people Embrace this as much as they have
well this is fundamentally the
malthusian point of view
um that there's only so much to go
around and so the more people uh the the
worse and therefore human numbers
activities and Liberties must be
severely constrained uh now the
corollary to this is there must be
someone to do the constraining uh and so
this world view was fundamentally uh a
justification for tyranny and therefore
intellectuals that espouse it will never
lack for sponsors
um the which was the case with Malthus
himself who was an employee of the East
India Company
um and uh you know first of all the
Malthus theory is completely false
um the uh actually it's been false
through all of human history and it was
spectacularly false and now if it's his
own time and more recently as the
population of Swords standard of living
has sort because what is standard living
uh crudely speaking it's product divided
by the number of people okay uh what
determines the the product available per
person equals on average the product
produced per person
which means and and what is product
produced per person that is technology
that is new technologies multiply what
each person can produce okay and where
do inventions come from they come from
inventors the more people the more
inventors the more inventors the more
inventions uh and inventions are
cumulative and this is why as the number
of people has gone up the standard of
living has gone up and not down
um I mean you know in mouth this is time
world had one billion people
and the average income per person per
uh
year was about two hundred dollars
about 50 60 cents a day in today's money
this is the world described in the
novels of Charles Dickens and Victor
Hugo in which there are starving people
in London and Paris the two most
advanced cities in the world okay uh
today the world average is ten thousand
dollars per person okay now it's higher
in advanced countries but that's the
average okay that's like Brazil okay
um
ten thousand is fifty times as much as
two hundred
so
the world population has increased
Sevenfold
the product per capita has increased 50
fold which is like seven squared which
means the total product has increased as
the population cubed
so malthusianism could not be more
counterfactual okay
and uh
one could go on along these lines
um
but these ideas are promoted the you
know Hitler
Hitler said
he took the opposite point of view and
in fact he he particularly singled out
this idea that science scientific
progress could
um
produce more per person than population
growth he called it a Jewish plot to
dissuade people from understanding the
necessity for war
that's what he said he said in other
words this idea that
human creativity
science okay can uh overcome resource
limitations is uh
undermining people's belief in the
necessity for war which he wanted people
to believe in okay
um and
okay Jews have contributed to the
advance of Science and Technology
certainly but certainly the idea that
Science and Technology can alleviate
scarcity is is not a Jewish plot it's
simply true
um and
as history proves history proves that
Wars for lebanstrom are unnecessary and
stupid uh and the the but that won't
stop them from happening because
there are people who need this bad idea
okay
and
it is fundamental to their power in
order it is the justification for
tyranny including totalitarian forms of
tyranny
um the the the the the and
frankly this is why I think onto Mars is
important it's not we're not going to
get oil from Mars okay to alleviate the
oil shortage uh we may I think we will
get inventions from Mars uh which will
help us a lot but the main thing we're
going to get from Mars is the truth
that it's not true that there's only so
much to go around here on Earth because
the Earth comes with an infinite sky and
if we work together we can throw it wide
open and there's no reason killing each
other fighting over provinces if by
working together we can open planets
what a beautiful way to wrap it up uh
Robert I I'll say for myself that I
absolutely loved speaking with you uh
I'm so glad we got to tap into what I
said earlier which is part of the
excitement and optimism about the future
um of human civilization frankly that we
don't often uh come across nowadays and
uh I really appreciate the time uh
you've given us we're going to ask you a
couple of questions uh from our audience
that only they will get to see for our
locals but uh before we do we've got one
final question for you as always which
is what's a one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be well you
should be talking about my books
okay there's enough of them to go around
yeah I've got
um a number of books the I mean if
you've got time for one it's the case
for Mars I um I mean it's
um published it in 96 updated in 2011
2021 the most recent Edition has an
endorsement by Elon Musk on the cover
um but we've got time for one of my
books that's the one okay I have a more
recent book it's called the case for
space it's also out there
and a book that may is on the flip side
of this which is called merchants of
despair
which is my attack on this anti-humanist
concept
um and showing how not only it's wrong
but how it has been responsible for uh
almost all the major human cause
disasters of the past 200 years and
uh so you know if you're up for that uh
also if you're not Technical and just
more into history and stuff that's the
book merchants of Despair and they're
all available on Amazon
well I can't wait I'm gonna stop I
haven't had a chance to read any of them
yet but I'm definitely going to start
with the case for Mars and I really
really look forward to that
okay Robert Zubin thank you so much for
coming on the show if people want to
find you online where is the best place
to do that well I'm president of the
Mars Society uh we have a website which
is at
marsociety.org that's fantastic thank
you so much uh don't uh go anywhere
because we're going to ask you a couple
of questions but for now Dr Robert Zuber
and thank you so much for coming on and
thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you with another brilliant
episode like this one or all show all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
any life form that goes to a new
environment is going to re-optimize for
that environment and
a taller and more lightly built might
very well be the way that martians
evolved
[Music]